well for many it is a time-honored
tradition just picking up one of those
delicious marie calendar pies ahead of
thanksgiving
or even a full feast if you'd like to
turkey all the trimming side dishes they
got it there
and this year was really no different
earlier today we stopped by one of the
restaurant locations here in the valley
obviously not the one where i was
standing in line today i didn't see our
crew
but there were still plenty of people
standing in line
every year we we have everything set up
we have the feast available we make it
easier convenient
for the customers to come purchase the
feast
everything's in it all you have to do is
reheat it line wasn't too bad 15-20
minutes maybe she says it's already a
stressful time for so many people and
they're just happy to help make the
holidays a little less hectic for folks
she also tells us they are starting back
up bright and early tomorrow morning at
7
a.m so they can sell all the rest of
those pies and meals